i read an article today from the bulwark
you guys know the bullwork sorry we're
all big
[Laughter]
the bullwork is awful they're like what
are they supposed to be like anti-trump
conservative or something never trumpers
but they they actually wrote something
particularly interesting they wrote how
the civil war could start
and they said in november of 2022
and uh
yeah oh boy and then i read it and i was
like they're not wrong
not it's it's speculative but here's
here's the here's the the the gist of
their opening thesa opening argument
during the midterm elections there's
going to be left-wing and right-wing
people outside of polling stations in
swing districts and in many areas of
critical importance
and what could happen is that the right
fearing fraud
is
watching every door watching every
entrance
of course in some of these jurisdictions
many of these people are armed or maybe
not but either way
in some of these areas you've got
democrats who believe that republicans
are paranoid q and extremists who are
going to disrupt the legitimate
elections because of their paranoid
conspiracy fervor
all that matters is two opposing
factions are at a polling place when
something looks amiss
and then you get one of either side
saying something is wrong here
an argument erupts because neither side
will see
what the other side sees it'll never
happen they'll say they just pulled the
ballot out i saw them what are they
doing who that's the second ballot the
the liberal side is gonna be like this
is it they're trying to steal the
election by lying about fraud again
and then what happens when it comes to
fighting doesn't matter what kind of
fight what happens when a polling place
gets shut down because of left and right
conflict now they went on to describe a
man drawing a gun a fight breaking out
and someone getting shot then someone
filming the video and the video going
viral showing a poll worker getting shot
and killed at a polling location
that's an interesting point that i think
it's possible not necessarily probable
what worries me is that fighting is in
my opinion probable with with 2020 this
is the first big election and more than
half of republicans believe there was
fraud so what's going to happen i think
is that you're going to see a lot of
areas conservatives trump supporters
republicans
out camping in front of these these
polling places 24 7.
you will potentially get a fight or an
obstruction to the point where they shut
a polling place down they shut down a
polling place in one area and all sudden
you've got procedural or statutory
conflict now there's going to be court
cases was it legitimate because people
couldn't go to vote people going back i
wasn't able to vote because the trump
supporters shut it down trump's report
is going to be like the left showed up
in anti-fun we were fighting if that
kind of conflict reaches polling
locations then i don't know if it's it's
it's like a shot heard around the world
fort sumter style start of the civil war
but the bulwark's argument is that could
be a catalyst for people saying
the election
doesn't work like it doesn't happen
something interrupts it and we can't
come out cleanly with knowing what
happened because this stuff could become
i don't know ubiquitous yeah that's what
shae's rebellion was was they shut down
a bunch of court proceedings they were
the courts were trying to take their
their property so the farmers went and
they surrounded the courthouses and were
like no and then the court the judge is
really well i'm not getting involved
because there's like a thousand dudes
that are gonna kill me if i do then they
made a bunch of arrests the government
did they arrested a bunch of the farmers
it was chaos and then eventually they
just pardoned everybody because you
can't move forward as a nation if you're
arresting half your citizenry there's
always going to be a left no matter
where you're always going to see people
to your right even if they're on the
left because they're right of you and
you may be
there's always going to be someone
opposite of you that's the nature of
humanity i actually tweeted this out i
wonder what you guys think about this if
a republic hacked its own election to
prevent a psychotic mob from taking over
the government democratically
one i thought that some you could argue
that that might be righteous and i'm
interested what you guys think about no
i think let's say there's a group of
psychotic
murderers that want to cut people open
as their cult ritual and there's more
enough of them that they can
democratically mob rule the vote system
and win
don't we have a republic intentionally
to prevent that
well sort of i mean first if you're
talking about people violating human
rights in the constitution then they
would be in violation of of our
government which is why the constitution
is so important if a group of weirdo
cults were like if you vote for us we'll
sacrifice children on an altar at a
pyramid to moloch or whatever like
overtly saying it and trying to do it
then it wouldn't be
those attempting to stop it would
actually be on the side of the continent
so if it was more subtle like we're
going to give transgender homelands to
kids we want to make kids trans like a
weird cult you can make it whatever you
want i see you're saying and this is why
i think civil war is and if a republic
we're like you know what
whatever that is there's a lot of them
but
america must reign supreme we're gonna
hack the election and make sure like is
that would that be ethical so here's the
issue no hacking the election is not
ethical and the issue of
the point of the republic is that
there's a lot of ideas that we don't
like and we think are violating our
rights and so long as this is done
procedurally and
there's there's a limit to uh
how should i say this if they're going
and saying vote for me and then we will
we will we will pass through legislation
the right to murder people we'd be like
no that's a violation of the
constitution i infected the death
penalty is as well
and even though we're seeing important
things what prevents the country from
falling apart prevents conflict war and
things getting worse is that we agree to
legislate things and debate them and
challenge them eventually however as you
mentioned is a good point we get to an
issue where they're like castrating kids
and bragging about i mean this this
stuff coming out from matt walsh is kind
of crazy the vanderbilt stuff yeah um
about the profit incentive and stuff
like that for doing this you get to a
point where it's like okay we've got a
very serious problem that's why we have
a convention of states we have many
legal mechanisms to deal with a
government you know that is not doing
its duties or is is overreaching and
things like that but i'll put it this
way
if they're outright violent constitution
then i don't think it's hacking the
election i think
they're the ones who are committing the
wrong what concerns me when it's not a
violation of the constitution it's just
a change in the culture that i i
personally think that's why we have a
republic is to prevent a mob of
democratic psychos changing it and i
think what happened was they think that
maga was a mob of democratic psychos so
they think that they're justified and
that's in the fortification of the
election and that time magazine put it
sorry i was just gonna say i i feel i
feel like this this particular
organization has not gotten enough press
but there is there is an existence the
committee for safe and secure elections
and it's law enforcement and election
officials working together
and um
you know i think that
all the listeners i i hope the left and
the right both look into this
organization because it's helping it's
helping to i think kind of guarantee
that that this doesn't erupt i know i
know what you're going to say no
stopping it from erupting is good but
here's here's here's the problem
if if joe biden
uh his brain is broken we assume it is
um i'm saying like if it is let's just
say diagnostically confirmed he's the
president and if you've got a problem
with that we have the was it the 25th
amendment i believe you have for
removing him and that's the process by
which we do it we don't allow
lunatics to be like our country's in
danger so therefore i will take it no no
no
you think donald trump's a threat that's
too bad people want him to be the leader
you do not unilaterally decide that you
are smarter and that your your
intelligence allows you to supersede
how our system is intended to function
although in the military and this isn't
good probably not good but there's like
they would frag their commanding officer
if they thought the commanding officer
was going to get them all killed they'll
be like no someone would slip a grenade
into the tent in the middle of the night
and the commanding officer would be dead
in the morning and then the next guy in
charge would be like okay i'm taking
over we're not going to attack i don't
know about that dude what are you
talking about it's a pretty horrible
aspect of like vietnam a lot of like
fragging the commander they'd kill the
commander if they didn't agree with they
thought the guy was going to get them
all that's the problem with the draft
that people have to serve a commander
they don't people people who don't want
to be there are forced to be there and
will say screw you yeah but now we have
robots that will take care of all the
fighting but anyway i i think it's also
important to note here that our
political differences have been
weaponized especially when it comes to
big tech social media which is connected
to the intelligence agencies that has
been pushing people further and further
on the political spectrum and you look
at the echo chambers created you look at
the radicalization you look at the
concentration and promotion of
negativity i think a lot of this brings
the hallmark of a divide and conquer
agenda that is being done deliberately
where today we are here in the united
states where there's legitimate yougov
polls talking about how 40 of americans
think that a civil war is likely within
a decade they think that for a very
specific reason because when you go
online that's all you see the negativity
the hate the fighting all of that front
page always and that has a psychological
effect on people and we are conditioned
towards the blue-collar working-class
people of this country fighting against
each other and that's the trajectory
that we are on that hopefully we could
avoid but but there's too much fuel
being added to this fire in order to
avoid this pathway i want to pause you
right there because it's not true the
democratic party is overwhelmingly well
off and there was a poll i think it
might have been yougov as well that
found when you poll people above 100 000
a year they overwhelming want joe biden
to remain president and when you poll
people under 100 000 of which there's
more they overwhelmingly want him
impeached it is not blue collar versus
blue collar it is it is suburban liberal
elites who are angry that working-class
people elected donald trump to be the
human molotov cocktail yeah but but this
case in north dakota who was it it
wasn't an elite person it was two people
going at it and one person killed
another person so so you know we're
talking about the average americans here
there are elite people calling the shots
here and saying hey i want him in power
and him in power but at the end of the
day who's going to be doing the fighting
neighbors people who are next to each
other people who are related to each
other people who are friends and family
members but because of the political
differences that have been weaponized in
this country they're going to be at odds
with each other and of course fighting
each other which is absolutely tragic
okay
and i can agree
but now let's let's let's dig a little
deeper
is it bad that powerful elites will
weaponize the differences between people
to divide and conquer maintain control
of course they've always done it
will you then decide to compromise with
those who are castrating children luke
no
so what's the solution
i think that i think that's that's one
particular
position that of course is strongly uh
divisive i think there's also a lot of
mental health disorders that lead to a
lot of people to be radicalized in that
particular position i think there's a
lot of unhealthy people i think there's
a lot of people who are not thinking
clearly i think the solution
you know is a very vast one and i talk
about it a lot but specifically that's
one specific a hyperbolic extreme
example there's other examples that i
think do divide uh that that do bridge
this gap things like epstein things like
federal overreach things like taxes
things like people of course just being
on taxes
yes and no because
at the end of the day who's happy paying
taxes i don't think anyone is i don't
think that
even even trump supporters that that
rapper lady that endorsed him i forgot
her name uh what was her name um
she just made a recent political
statement
nicki minaj she even made a whole video
would be like where are my taxes going
yeah where's my money cardi b cardi b
was like where's my money
where's my money
taxes
the military-industrial complex i i
think there's a big push back against a
lot of these things because at the end
of the day they don't serve the interest
of the american people the american
people know that they're being screwed
but every time they're being screwed
they're being told hey the other person
did it to you but hey the other person
did it too and it's not just like that
it's not black and white well i don't
think that we should just gloss over the
trans stuff and i think that we need to
make these extremists answer for what
their extremes are you know i think that
taxes are one thing and everybody can
kind of agree on on on how you know you
don't want to pay too much or whatever
but you know we're we're at a point
where
like
you know i'm sending my kids to school
i'm thinking about where i'm going to
live i'm thinking about where you know
what what communities i want to be in
and who i want my neighbors to be and
it's just gotten to a point where
i uh
i don't think people should be allowed
to just not talk about it anymore like
if you're going to be a part of this
party who's doing this to children who's
supporting these children then i want
you to answer for it i want to know
i want to know why you think this is
okay like this this can't just be oh
well you know this is just a fringe
thing like this this isn't really
happening it is happening and you know
the vanderbilt
story i mean i i we have to make people
answer for it yeah we should definitely
talk about the matt walsh stuff later on
but you know as it pertains to divisive
uh-ness in rhetoric and things like that
there are people who i think the media
wants us divided for sure
i think uh i think for the most part you
know fox news has their problems
tucker is a bit abrasive but
he's okay
i you know maybe not necessarily the way
i i do things he's he's much more
comedic and he showed like a picture of
lori lightfoot as beetlejuice
that's not that's not the kind of thing
we do i know luke's a big fan he loves
sucker
i think he he's one of the few people
that actually criticized donald trump
and one of the few people that was
actually able to put his feet to the
fire and call him out on a lot of
important issues i think he's good i
think he is and i think for the most
part the media is overwhelmingly liberal
aside from the one you know channel and
then uh they're manipulating people
through just lying
emotions
culture yeah like i was watching video
game play footage last night pixelated
apollo what's up dude playing some
mountain mountain blade 2 banner lord
you love call me at some point gamers
started going let's go boys come on boys
let's go boys and it's all about the
boys and they talk about boys like their
audience are boys and i'm concerned that
it's like an insult like it's like i'm
i'm just not comfortable with women so
i'm comfortable with guys let's have our
boys in the military there's boys but
what's happening what's happening is
young girls are watching the video and
they're like i want to be part of this
because if a girl is ever like let's go
girls it's me and the girls tonight i
get really annoyed at that i'm like why
are you like excluding me from this
conversation so i think young girls are
seeing this boy's rhetoric and they want
to be boys i think the problem is that
there's a lot of women who like i mean
lydia and i were actually talking about
this before the show but i was a tomboy
when i when i was growing up i wanted to
be a boy sandlot was a huge movie i was
not only in love with benny the jet
rodriguez i wanted to be benny the jet
rodriguez and if if i had some you know
booby teacher
uh and i was being encouraged to to act
these you know silly childish immature
thoughts out i mean
you know i i might not be a mother today
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you